here is martine perez on top of the
mound
and that's in there for strike three
put him away at 93 miles an hour quick
start for martine
[Applause]
now the red sox get ready to face the 24
year old native of springville alabama
casey mize you miss there you miss here
it's 2-2 there you go that's right
beautiful pitch
here's the 1-1 swinging a pop-up shallow
center field this could be trouble on
comes hernandez slides he makes the
catch what a play
he went sliding on the wet grass and
grabbed it reaching off to his glove
side he made that look easy
[Applause]
so red sox can make it out and get the
first run in as bogarts is safely into
third
and here's arroyo
[Music]
broken bat
ground ball
is the shovel and close there as the run
comes in to score one-nothing red sox
got to get it on the corner here though
1-2 wave and a miss second strike out of
the night for casey mize
and it's first and second nobody out
willy castro on deck and a one-two pitch
here to good room
and struck him out 88 miles an hour
right at the knee to fanning
candelario and cabrera leading off their
bases with one away here's the two
strike pitch
to castrol
in there for strike three back to back
parachutes looking mr castro
two ones
got something going here gotta leave it
up to jacoby
this one smoke to left a base hit
candelaria is going to be bobbled in
left field by francie cordero
candelario scores
all the way up to third
goes miguel cabrera and jacoby jones has
tied it at one two down runners leading
off second and third
and that one into right field on a
charge renfro and he's got it to retire
the side we are all tied up here in the
fourth inning one of peace
[Music]
casey mize shuts him down there in the
fourth we remain tied at one his third
punch out of the night and he gets
renfro to swing underneath it
that's a good good hand yeah at times
yes in there strike three
ryder will take a seat as martin perez
gets him another pair of shoes oh we're
talking all pair of shoes tonight all
five of them
so it becomes the pressure point of the
night
for martine
castro without a home run
on the infield that'll pay off everybody
gets back but out number two oh that'll
do it a broken bat soft flying drive to
second base with the infield did didn't
even hit the grass
can you pick him up again single here
could score two
one two to jones oh drives one to left
and that's going to be off the wall
that'll score them both jacoby jones has
been huge here tonight
hit a three-run homer last night
had a single that scored a run earlier
and now
with two away a two-run single off the
monster to give the tigers their first
lead in the series line drive single off
the green monster 3-1 tigers in the six
tried to get inside one more time and he
put a severe buggy whip on that baby
that hit off the green monster so
that fast going to be off the bat he
made contact on that
what was that
going to hit the hangar again got a foul
ball
got the knob off his hand oh that's off
his hand it's not a foul ball that's off
his hand why is he sitting at home plate
wouldn't you be going to first base well
they ruled it a foul ball
and they are going to review this yeah
he's got hit
hello they're going to send him to first
to hit batsman so it's overturned
and that is gonna load up the bases for
a hunter renfro well he's had it going
on the last couple games rob parent
throws the right guy up there he's been
hot he gets out of this it's a good one
righty on righty battle
swinging the ground ball chopped to
third backhanded by candelario cross the
diamond to cabrera and casey mize does
the job
he gets a routine ground ball out off
the bat of hunter renfro on the first
pitch and casey mize strands three
very good effort by casey meisten
tonight in total control had good
composure made his pitches
and to me that's his best start so far
as a detroit tiger
here's the 2-1 from saumora
and a fly ball in the left center very
shallow corner coming on coming on and
made the catch
oh fine played by franchi out there well
snow cone i think yeah he showed it but
he made the play three to one tigers
so here we go tying run to the plate two
down in the seventh ged at 3 43 with
nine home runs tops in the majors 27
runs banded in
[Music]
high fly ball right center field that's
way back there on the run jones kiss it
goodbye
jd martinez the opposite field
and he has tied the game 3-3
he beat him on the first couple of
fastballs but he didn't beat him there
missed on a slider came back with the
fastball
and he loses it in the bullpen that's jd
right there yeah that ball was hit hard
you know in the rain
in all the conditions we've been dealing
with tonight that ball was smoked into
the bullpen
sinking fastball
comes right back into the barrel of his
bat
opposite field into the bullpen
tie ball game oh that is jd right there
that is a powerful shot as jerry
mentioned in these conditions
winning run at first base near the
bottom of the ninth inning
[Music]
rafael has largely been silenced tonight
he did walk in the third inning but he's
over three
strikeout two tappers to second red sox
looking for a hero in the ninth inning
he lines that one down into the corner
that's a fair ball all the way to the
wall
kiki taking off for third he will stop
there as the throw is hustled in on a
double by devers nasty slider and he
rifles it down the left field line and
he walked intentionally to set up a
force at any base it's either
pitch to jd or pitch to senator bogarts
not easy
bogey hitting 351 the pitch
there's a shot
line drive grossman makes the play out
there in the alley
and saves the game for detroit at least
for now we're headed to extra innings at
fenway great play by robbie terrific
play
all right so runners at the corners for
jamer candelario
and akil badu will pinch run for
jonathan scope
a couple of hits for candelario both
infield singles drives one to deep right
field way back it goes and that ball is
gone
pounded that one to right field it's a
three-run blast
6-3 tigers in the 10.
yeah
you smoked that
how quickly this game changes i mean
that ball that left bogots is bad you
thought that was the game was over
totally he thought it was over and all
of a sudden
you're looking it up a 6-3 deficit
we'll stroke that one that's going to
drop down for a base hit that's going to
bring in a run
xander is in to touch home plate
and that'll make it six four little tie
run at the plate right now ball wouldn't
hit very hard by gonzales
bounty ball up the middle slip it's
knocked down and no play as a run comes
in to score
gonzalez will touch home plate this is a
one run game
red sox rallying for two of their own
after giving up three in the top of the
inning six to five tigers hanging on by
their fingernails the one two
oh
he strikes him out looking michael
fulmer's first save
and the tigers in 10
beat the red sox 6-5